[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road
2000 as always my name is caleb denby
and this
is the most important broadcast going on
tonight uh tonight
i wanted to actually take you through
some of my favorite games
from the recently concluded air things
masters
this was another tournament held on
chess 24
part of these chess tours that magnus
carlsen is spearheading this one i
believe called the
champions chess tour and the air things
masters
was definitely um different
than any of the preceding tournaments
that we've seen
coming from chess 24. the format itself
was largely the same
but when we got to the knockout stage
after a preliminary
qualifying stage we saw none other than
magnus carlson hikaru nakamura u.s
champion wesley so
these three players who were likely seen
as the the pre-tournament favorites
actually all got eliminated in the first
round of the knockouts
to you know seeming seemingly underdog
opponents
so i wanted to look at some of those
games but first off i want to show you a
game from
the match between daniel dubov
and maxine veshilogrov because this i
think is safe to say
is probably the wildest game of the
entire event
i didn't get a chance to analyze each
and every game but i just have a very
difficult time imagining
that any game was crazier than this one
as you can expect
between openly opening novelist dubov
and you know nidorf aficionado mvl
so so let's see what happens here in
this game we have duboff playing e4
c5 by mvl knight f3 d6
of course mvl uh never plays anything
but the najdorf
except when he does and we have bishop
b5 check so you know dubov
not throwing down the gauntlet entering
the extreme body of theory in
mvl's night or instead playing bishop b5
which is
the trend these days uh we see mvl
selecting knight d7
actually all three ways to block this
check are perfectly acceptable
and then deubav castle's king side all
very normal so far
we see a6 by mvl and this
is the downside to activating this
bishop so early on this diagonal
it can on occasion be subject to tempo
moves like a6
and black will often look to take some
extra space on the king's side
we have now the slightly strange looking
move bishop d3 but
it makes a lot of sense when you realize
that there's really no good place
for this bishop if you were to put this
bishop on c4
it would eventually be kicked away by a
b5 with tempo
and it doesn't have a lot of future on
this diagonal in view of any e6 pushes
by black
if you were to drop it all the way back
to e2 you actually are looking to use
this e-file to your advantage and so
we arrive at bishop d3 not stepping into
b5 with tempo
and sort of giving this bishop a place
to say stay
also notably a very common idea is to
play the move c3 and actually drop this
bishop back to c2
where it looks like it makes a lot more
sense supporting
the center but none of that here today
we get knight g
to f6 and in fact we do see c3
by white and mvl expands now on
the queen side uh and do bob's opening
idea here
is actually not a new one uh whenever
you see
black playing moves like a6 b5 early on
in the opening
or really either side making any large
pawn
advance on either side of the board a
very very common idea
is to try and overextend these pawns or
prove that these pawns are already
overextended so how is white going to
achieve this goal early on in this game
well it's
quite simple whenever black is pushing
like this you'll see this idea in the
royal lopez
this idea in many many openings often
times a4
is a great way to start breaking down
these light squares so
this bishop perhaps not so bad over here
on d3 after all
still applying a lot of pressure on this
relevant diagonal and by the way
saving white a tempo by defending the e4
pawn
from the attack on from knight g to f6
so a4 and now black is faced with a
decision
it is perfectly fine to play the move c4
and force this bishop to move again
but these light squared woes are really
not going to be going away
for example a takes b5 a takes b5 rook
takes a8
bishop takes a8 and knight a3 and you
can see
in numerous games played here one
between hare krishna and giri
one between svidler and naponnashi one
between uh anu
mujichuk and peter svidler you know all
these games this has been done before
and in my opinion this looks better for
white than what we see
in the game so what happens in the game
what's the alternative well you can play
c4 and try to save this pawn
or you can play as nvl does and give it
up
in exchange for pressure on the center
and that's exactly
what we see happening here duboff
accepts the pawn with a takes b5
we get a takes b5 rook takes a8
queen takes a8s activating the queen and
further attacking this pawn on e4 and
now
we do see dubov start to deviate from uh
better known territory uh this position
has been reached a number of times
and normally players are playing the
move bishop takes b5 but duboff selects
this move
knight a3 instead which is a fairly
unknown move
this has really never really appeared at
high
levels of play so let's see how
mvl decides to handle it while this move
is relatively unknown i wouldn't be
surprised if mvl
still has some theory in his head
regarding this move
because it is fairly natural we saw it
make an appearance in the other line
with c4
and here the idea is the same black is
simply looking to pressure this pawn
on b5 so before i show you what mvl
played i would like to ask the chat room
what are uh you know your two main
candidate moves here
right obviously one candidate move is to
capture this pawn on
e4 but is there anything else you guys
in the chat
are considering here i think there's one
more move that is really worth a look
ah and peter peterson is tardy that will
be going on the official record
but uh you know all is forgiven all is
forgiven
so chess king has the right idea this
move of b4
i think is really important to talk
about here uh and it's actually never
really been tried so i think b4 might
have actually been an improvement
over what we saw in the game from mvl
now why play this move b4 uh why is it
so important
to to sort of try and preserve this pawn
because at surface
on the surface it looks as though we are
just giving white
some time to further attack on the queen
side here
and i think the reason is whenever you
give up the pawn as
mvl does in the game we see
a trait of these pieces and then knights
uh
into b5 you are actually losing control
of more squares
than you would with this pawn on b4 uh
and you can see this
after black's next move queen b7 now we
see
pawn c4 and this is why i
sort of suspect that pawn to b4 might be
an improvement over what we saw
in the game once this knight actually
gets cemented on the b5 square
i think black is sort of in some trouble
now what could have been done to avoid
this honestly not much
you do have the opportunity to take on
e4 with the queen
but after knight takes b5 it's difficult
to find an improvement
uh for black aside from playing
something like queen c6
which we could have seen in the other
line anyways so how does b4 actually
help with this well after you see
knight to b5 queen to b8 if white were
to play the move c4 here
now a huge huge difference is that we
haven't committed
to taking on e4 yet so we do have a way
to challenge this knight with something
like bishop c6
a second huge difference is that this
knight absolutely has
no squares to move to so it's
effectively
you know trapped on this powerful
outpost on
on b5 so this pawn on b4 i think was
actually worth keeping around
uh it does sort of go against natural
intuition to give up a b
pawn for a central pawn uh like the e4
pawn or
or to not accept this trade of a
powerful central pawn for your b-pawn
but in this case white's attacking
powers
are just you know too strong here so
bishop takes e4 i'm claiming is a pretty
big opening mistake here
by mvl and dubov proving once again
that in these well-established lines he
is sort of the the guy to look to
for new ideas interesting ideas and they
seem to be working well for him in all
of these events so bishop takes e4
and we do see bishop e4 94 knight b5 and
now
queen to b7 by white
so c4 is dubov's choice maybe other
moves were also quite good for white
but i think this takes a solid
positional advantage
out of the opening simply because this
knight is very very strong
and black is left without a way to
challenge it once again
with the light squared bishops being
traded off the board
so continuing on uh all is not lost here
for black we do see the move
e6 developing out uh and this is met by
d3
knight e to f6 and now i'm gonna claim
dubov starts to let things slip just a
little bit
so uh wait to move here what do you guys
think
should be played what do you think
should be played
with the white pieces
uh there's a question in the chat about
why couldn't black
play the move d5 and i will go back to
that because that's an interesting
question
and it possibly relates to white's next
move
queen a4 and conquer has been suggested
always fun
the simple move rookie one is on the
table h4 is also
on the table conquer the a file
has been said in the chat and actually
none of these moves
are the the quote unquote winning or or
correct move here
uh what duboff plays is also actually
none of those moves
diego has found the move that super gm
dubov played
which is the move d4 and this is sort of
the the principled move right you want
to open things up in the center
while the black king is still stuck
there and d4 is the optimal way
to uh to do this you play d4 you're able
to play moves like d take c5
activate yourself along the d file and
like i said open up the center while the
opponent's king
is stuck there uh instead though the
rather surprising move
bishop f4 may have actually been
the best choice for white in this
position
and the idea is quite simple you want to
attack
this d6 pawn and get at these weak dark
squares
now uh obviously this raises the
question what happens
on e5 and that is where things could
have started to go
a little bit bonkers uh white can of
course play rook e1
and that is why e5 is not the seemingly
tempo gaining problem-solving move that
you might expect
and after the move bishop d7 white to
move here
again chat can you find the killer
follow-up
to white's idea of bishop f4
and shun in the chat i believe does have
the answer
although maybe he was answering a
different question the answer is still
do bob's move of d4 bishop f4 just would
have been
a pretty wild and very very effective
way of ripping
open the center even more quickly than
the immediate d4 that we saw in the game
what's the difference well the
difference is by inducing this move e5
and then following it up very very
quickly we no longer have to settle for
capturing a c5 pawn
now we get to capture a an e5 pawn which
is of course
much more effective at opening the
center and also
white is just going to be winning this
pawn if black tries to get out of dodge
here
we do see that uh white just simply wins
this pawn in the center of the board
has the more active pieces and will will
likely have a winning advantage
here in the game so bishop f4 would have
been a really interesting opportunity
for dubov
but we don't see him finding it here
instead d4 which
like i said i don't want to rag on
dupont this is sort of the principled
move
if you don't see these crazy tactics d4
is the right way to go
the lesson to take away from both of
these moves i want to say
is that while moves like queen b3 and
queen a4
might be tempting it is far better to
open things up in the center
when your opponent has yet to castle and
you have this developmental advantage
you just
you need to rip open files around the
king
and d4 and bishop f4 are the ways to
achieve that
moves like rookie one also i think fit
this
this uh principle pretty well but d4 and
bishop f4
are both more immediate so d4 played in
the game
and now we do see black going on the
defensive i do want to also mention this
idea
that of d5 that was suggested i think
the problem here
is again that's uh you're sort of
running into
some problems on your dark squares right
d3 and bishop f4
and now you don't even have the
opportunity to play e5 with your pawn
uh leaving the dark squares so d5 a nice
little idea to try to remove
the defender but unfortunately not going
to be doing
uh enough here in this position so d3
and d4 played in the game we do see
bishop e7
mvl simply trying to get developed and
get out of the center before it is too
late
and here we see the move d5 by duboff
and this was a fairly interesting
decision
because it does allow mvl the
opportunity to play the move played in
the game
which is e5 and uh
on the surface these moves all look very
intuitive
right why would do bob play d5 allowing
mvl to lock up the center
and play e5 and this is a classic
example
of transferring advantages that that is
what
do bob is trying to do here uh mvl's
king
stuck in the center is a very temporary
very static or very dynamic
advantage to use the term from
chessbooks meaning
dynamic versus static dynamic advantages
are always changing
they're short-lived you have to make use
of them immediately whereas static
advantages
are long term and so by using
the fact that black's king is stuck in
the center duboff plays d5
daring uh black to open up the e file
uh mvl of course in the rapid game is
not committed
or is not ready to commit to this
opening of the file endangering his king
so he opts to close things down but this
is actually a pretty big
concession statically so no longer is
black's king
in all that much danger if we are going
to get castled with the center closed
but instead the light squares have been
drastically weakened and that is sort of
or what should have been fatal for mvl
in this game of course things
get crazier uh things do get crazier
so how do we take advantage of this
advance of this
weakening move of e5 it turns out that
mvl is not completely safe just yet
and the move to do it is pretty
intuitive what squares does e5 weaken
well it's f5 and d5 can't really make
use of d5
but we can make use of the f5 square
so we do see the move knight h4
appearing on the board
and this is how dubov is able to keep up
the pressure
and get back to an advantage it turns
out by the way
that the best thing for mvl to do here
was
actually take up the gauntlet here and
play d takes or e takes d5 just opening
up this e file
with the point that after the move
rookie one
black can temporarily try and fix things
with knight e5 and we do get we do get
to castle the king
sort of just in time uh and the
difference between
castling the king here and castling the
king in the position we just looked at
is that there's no devastating knight f5
move coming in
because black simply hasn't created all
these light squared weaknesses
that we see so e5 mvl's
sort of second mistake here uh not
playing the slightly counter-intuitive
but correct move e takes d5 easy thing
to miss here because these players
it's rapid chess their intuitions are
fantastic of course
but chess is always a game of specifics
and this is why
you know extra time on the clock leads
to better chess games you need to
calculate things like
decisions like these out and the players
simply don't have time to do it in these
rapid games
which can be what makes them so exciting
now the intuitions take over again we
see dubov
aiming to capitalize on the weakness
made by mvl
uh castles here would in a sense be
unplayable because knight f5 is simply
too strong this is just
a classic double attack the bishop is
attacked and the pawn on d6
is attacked and you cannot save both
pieces
uh you can play the move knight b6 to
try and add some intrigue here
but a simple move like b3 is going to be
good enough
queen d7 for the moment would keep all
the material
but these are very very powerful knights
and white would maintain
some advantage mvl sort of fearing this
knight f5 move
tries to get the best of both worlds
just like miley cyrus and plays the move
g6
saying i would like to castle and not
see a knight land on
f5 now there's an obvious downside to
this
every move uh every pawn move that you
make has the drawback of creating
weaknesses
and in this case it's the dark squares
that are
going to be horribly horribly weakened
mvl
was probably relying on his next move of
bishop f8
to try and reclaim some of these dark
squares
but there is an absolutely stunning move
available
to doobov in this position now it wasn't
played in the game
but i would like to give everybody in
the chat at home their shot at glory
here
if you can find the winning move for
white here
i will be absolutely floored this one
is a rather unique tactic
and someone in the chat remembers the
game but promises not to spoil it i
appreciate that
knight takes g6 sacrifice that is not
going to be
uh what we're looking for here and yeah
already three people in the chat
actually do have the move
it is the incredibly surprising bishop
g7
not very often that you see two bishops
in contact and
one bishop just nudging slightly closer
to the other one
not capturing it not moving away but
landing on g7 so
how can you begin to understand the
seemingly nonsensical move
like why why not just move the rook away
and it comes down
to bishop takes h6 not being a threat in
this position as seen in the game
do you have plays f4 offering up this
bishop for free
of course this allows the fork of knight
takes d6
but in a future position once this queen
moves out of the way
then you might find bishop takes h6
being a relevant factor
so bishop g7 is simply the correct order
of operations
to ensure that you don't have a bishop
hanging on h6
at the end of a second crazy tactic so
bishop g7 is only the beginning here
so what's the point of bishop g7 well
after rook to g8
we are actually going to trade off our
powerful dark squared bishop
on f6 and then play the winning tactic
so who in the chat
sees the actual points the point of
bishop g7
was amazingly to trade the bishop for a
knight
that was the point but now now that we
have
uh you know traded this bishop off made
sure that it's not hanging at the end of
the line
how do we actually win the game how do
we actually win the game
apparently again mater has a video on
this game which makes sense
because it is rather crazy
apparently john nunn has named the type
of move that bishop g7 is as co-linear
very cool very cool queen a4 looks
tempting queen a4 queen a4 queen a4
knight d6 has been suggested so the best
way to continue here is actually not
queen a4
but a similar threat of queen to b3
now what's the difference both moves
make the threat of knight takes d6
uh trying to win the queen right this is
the idea of both
but amazingly the idea of queen b3 is to
activate the rook
along the a file and this is the winning
tactic
that was missed in the game for example
we have to do something with our queen
lest knight takes d6 appear on the board
uh
so queen b8 would likely be the choice
here to defend
d6 further and start to begin the
process
of saving the king but now simply rook
a1
is an unstoppable threat black can try
to develop
but the final tactic to end the
variation
is the move rook a8 pinning the queen to
the king
and with the fork of knight to c7 check
to follow
absolutely insane tactics available
in this game uh really really crazy
stuff
and fun fun to look at so one more time
let's see what happens if queen b3 was
played
first now the difference here is queen
b8 would likely still be played
but now if you try the same fun tactic
like i said
eventually it was going to become
relevant that your bishop is hanging on
h6
and now is that time you still can play
rook a8
and take the queen but the difference
now is
that black actually has two minor pieces
uh
and a rook for the queen and it's
actually black who's winning in this
position
with all of that material so uh
really crazy stuff here to find the move
bishop g7 would be absolutely ridiculous
with the point of saving your bishop
preemptively before initiating
a tactic now i do actually want to try
and give
a practical recommendation for people
in slower time control over the board
games obviously these two players
operating under limited time controls
having to think very very quickly
but oftentimes in your over the board
tournament chess games
you're going to be looking at potential
tactics and finding that there is just
you know one little thing wrong with
them and
it's a very difficult line to to walk
between managing your time efficiently
making sure you're not
super tanking into a line that's not
going to work anyways
and understanding and objectively
realizing
if those problems can be solved so how
can you arrive at a move like bishop g7
in an over the board
standard time control game well you
start with the move like queen b3
making a threat right queen b3 is the
easy move to find you just want to
threaten to take your opponent's queen
you want to activate your pieces why not
play queen queen b3
and then it's pretty easy to arrive at a
move like queen b8
trying to defend everything and then
it's pretty uh well i guess not pretty
easy
but you you want to continue making
threats and you might find yourself
arriving at this rook a1 to rook 8 idea
however it just doesn't quite work
because your bishop on h6
is hanging so we're back at our initial
position and you're thinking about these
queen b3 things
and then you realize hey this bishop is
kind of a problem
can i solve this problem and that is how
you can
attempt to arrive at the move of bishop
g7
i'm not saying you always will nine
times out of ten you're still going to
miss it
but that's how you can start thinking
about crazy moves like this
you don't start with bishop g7 you start
with the forcing move
go down the variation see what's wrong
with it and see if you can fix the
problem so just a note
on the thought process to take during
these crazy games
you start with the forcing moves and
then the correct moves
sort of come from there even if the
forcing moves aren't themselves
the correct ones okay enough of that
though
in the game f4 is played and we see e4
by
mvl and then do bob actually does start
with this move of queen b3
now we see queen b8s and i'm absolutely
sure
that dubov spotted this idea of rook a1
to rook a8
he also realized though that this bishop
was a problem
on h6 the issue now is it is a little
bit too late for funny bishop g7 stuff
because this pawn on d6 is now defended
and the bishop could just be captured
so instead duboff settles for bishop
takes f8
but now mvl's sensing some danger
decides it's time to get the king
off of the back rank and plays will not
offer the background yet
but plays king f8 getting the king away
from these knight jumps
getting the king a lot closer to safety
on the g7 square
and now white's advantage is sort of
greatly diminished white is still a bit
better
but the advantage is diminished and i
just want to say
this has been some pretty stellar
practical defense
by mvl now once again he has played
plenty of mistakes so far
in the game and that's why i added the
qualifier practical defense
because objectively black was lost out
of the opening here white had a winning
attack a winning tactic
straight out of the opening but
practically in a rapid time control game
even at the top level you have to rely
on principles and intuition and mvl's
principles
and intuitions were telling him that he
had to keep the center closed or else he
was going to get murdered so he plays e5
which is objectively the wrong move
but does serve the purpose of keeping
things closed he tries to keep the enemy
pieces away
uses this opportunity to try to break
free meets f4
with the practical move e4 trying to
keep four files closed
and then after queen b3 he spots his
opportunity
to sort of save his position when the
winning tactic was missed
so that is what i mean when i say great
practical defense
mvl tried his best to keep things closed
forced his opponent to try and find a
wild and crazy line
and now that dubov didn't find that line
yes he still has some advantage
but black is definitely not out of the
chess game yet
with sort of the end being in sight for
this
king we see queen g3 now by
dubov still trying to keep up the
pressure against the black king no
matter where he may
reside some threats of breaking through
against d6 still exist
this move runs into knight h5 though
with the white queen now getting kicked
around
we don't see queen g5 because this would
run into the surprising move
of h6 when the queen again
is going to be pushed around even knight
h5
with some ideas of repeating the
position instead we see a different idea
queen c3 trying to target this rook back
here on h8
mvl simply slides it out of the way uh
plays rook g8
we now see g4 by daniel dubov again
trying his best to rip things open while
mvl tries his best to keep things locked
down net hf6 is the only move
uh now g5 and we finally see this
knight on b5 actually sort of being
taken advantage of here uh the idea
suggested in the chat a long time ago
was to play pawn to d5
trying to take advantage of this pawn's
overworkedness
over workedness if that is a word uh
instead now we actually see knight takes
d5
with a similar idea and this is where
the the tide of the game
starts to starts to change now yes
black's pieces still look slightly
awkward
but now rather than attacking for free
white is attacking at a price
and that price uh is central pawns
and more weaknesses in in the rest of
the pawns
right g moves like g4 g5 don't come for
free
right you are giving up a lot when you
say to yourself
i'm never going to have the move g3 to
solidify my structure
i'm never going to have you know safety
around my king
if my opponent's pieces ever do free
themselves
and so now white is definitely going to
have to be very very cautious for the
rest of the game
and seemingly out of nowhere mvl is
somewhat back in the driver's seat uh
queen d2
was played in the game now simply knight
b4
heads for the d3 square and mvl is
finally trying to make use of his
central advantage
uh dubov continues sort of in the only
way that you can reasonably expect here
uh in for a penny right so f5 is the
continuation uh further
trying to rip things open around the
king and trying to get checkmates
uh almost even at any cost knight d3 now
by mvl
and again both players really sticking
to their roles here knight d3 is a very
you know stopping up move trying to keep
the queen
out of play keep things locked down and
that is mvl's only goal
the difference now is he actually has
something to to hold on to here he has
an extra pawn
and now a powerful knight so it's not
just
strict defensive play for mvl it's
defensive play
with the idea that he's going to have a
winning advantage if he can survive this
attack
uh f6 is dulov's move and this is a very
very difficult uh decision
that dubov had to make right you would
love love love
to play the move f takes g6 and open up
this f file for your rook
but the unfortunate news is it's simply
not going to be
good enough you're going to see a black
knight landing
on this e5 square and controlling all of
the
the opened up squares that you tried to
make and if you try to play
i don't know something something crazy
even queen e2 for example
d5 is is sort of on tap and this opening
up of the position
no longer really even helps white
because black's pieces have managed to
find such activity
so quickly so in the game
f6 is played and this is a really really
committal move because yes
now you have this annoying thorn in
black side here
but it can actually be attacked and it
does
lock down this f-file seemingly almost
forever
so mvl's next move is pretty important
as well you don't really want to let
these pawns stand
right in front of your king so h6 is a
natural way
to try and break these down notably mvl
is not really concerned
with giving up this h-pawn it's all
about king safety for mvl
because this powerful e-pawn and
eventually a d5 break
are the winning plan here for maxine
rook h8 is also very important to make
sure this pawn doesn't go any further
allowing a queen
into the game queen g5 is duboff's
natural
follow-up again bringing more pieces in
but this attack is now doomed to fail
uh once we see knight seven to e5 that
is really truly
the end of white's attack these two
knights together
stop any sort of sort of incursions
along the central files
they defend the key weak squares in
black's camp
and furthermore they are taking away a
myriad of squares
in the white camp as well right
offensive and defensive pieces these are
the most powerful knights
maybe i have ever seen okay
duboff is not one to give up though and
tries a different path to invade
down the a file a path that we were
looking at before but now
is is coming sadly too late for dubai
the uh really critical move here by mvl
uh is king g8s surprisingly
and the idea is simply to give yourself
the option
to play the move king h7 and bring your
other rook into the game
rook a7 is the natural follow-up by
dubov
and notably there are still traps in the
position
even with these powerful powerful
knights moves like king h7
still could get black into trouble due
to tactics like rook takes f7
when this is no fun for the black king
but of course mvl doesn't miss this and
now plays the move queen f8
uh trying to get rid of these attackers
on the king's side and just sort of
secure victory
knight c7 is the move played by daniel
dubov
and unfortunately for dubob this is the
the last moment
where he was really still in the game
mvl simply captures this pawn on h6
and after this black is is much much
better
there was still one last chance for
duboff to sort of be in there with the
fight and
that was if dubov managed to find the
slightly strange idea
of knight e6 after f takes e6 rook g7
check
would have been nice but here believe it
or not
but i can actually just sacrifice the
queen play rook h7
take on g7 and be be quite close
to uh to a winning advantage thanks to
the very powerful
e4 pawn that is very quickly going to
threaten
to queen but 96
not found by the way after 96 if you try
some random move like queen c8
of course this is losing the rook on
h6 also importantly
the idea uh that was played in the game
uh would not work against knight e6 so
what was played in the game
rook a8 was played in the game seemingly
winning a queen
but the absolutely killer tactic here
for black
i'll let you guys at home try and find
it black to move and win the game what
should we do
what should we do
nicholas says can you explain queen g3
uh yes so you're saying it's looking at
a well protected pawn i'll jump back
back to that moment
that last line i said the rook retreats
but wasn't there a fork
um i don't believe so i believe
that this knight has the fork covered
for the moment but this
is very very relevant so yeah you guys
are right you can actually play it in
either move order
but mvl chooses queen takes a8 here in
this position
and the idea that follows is knight
takes a8
would be met by rook takes h4 and
astonishingly
there's simply no good way to continue
for white here um white
has a queen for a rook and a knight but
it cannot capture this rook due to
knight f3 check
that if three check is a threat anyways
and if you move the queen to one of the
only two safe squares
uh on a square like e3 or
d2 for example you're just going to get
met with knight f3 check
rook takes h2 and rook f2 is
impossible to stop so what we see in the
game
is actually not knight takes a8 but
queen takes h6
trying to play for checkmate but now mvl
finds some very accurate continuations
here with queen a1 check
queen takes b2 check and knight f2 check
drawing the king out
and then successfully uh
finding the final tactic queen takes h2
here
to go ahead and secure the game by
getting the queen off the board and now
enjoying fewer than
three pawns uh as an advantage
so really really crazy stuff here i'm
going to
zoom through the rest of the game king
f4 was played attacking the e4 pawn but
now after knight f5
there's no good place to really put this
knight you can play something like
knight g2
but then this guy is going to fall so
instead we see captures captures
the king cannot even capture this though
because the e pawn would promote
and then the game lasts
not very much further we do see those
three pawns
good enough to win in most end games
so why 96 one more time
well against 96 this idea of verb takes
h4
is a lot less effective because white
can now simply
take this back and there's no way to
invade with
with the black queen here we can
still pick up this queen sorry not not
allowing it with check
but now after this we cannot actually
capture
on f8 because rook a8 would be would be
made really
really wild stuff this game so i was
asked in chat to explain queen g3
so i will uh way back here
so what was the point of queen g3 so it
wasn't actually to attack the g6 pawn
the idea was to hint at f5 and get after
this d6 pawn using the diagonal
from g3 rather than the file it was
moved to but
i'm with you i don't think it was the
greatest idea because this move knight
h5
seemed to be really really effective at
pushing this queen out
it would be great if we can somehow
invade along these g file squares
but you simply cannot right you just get
pushed back
and you're doing nothing but repeating
the moves
if you go queen g3 okay
uh so other questions on this game other
questions on this game
yeah crazy good nights crazy good nights
i tend to agree
all right hopefully you guys enjoyed
this one then i am gonna move along was
this blitz i believe this was a rapid
game
uh they get uh i think 15 minutes in
some some kind of increment
i do not fully remember off the top of
my head
but with with that i do want to move on
to some of those early upsets
that we uh that i spoke about at the top
of the show here
for example this one between levon
aronian and takaru nakamura now
it does feel very very strange to say
that levonaronian uh
is you know upsetting anybody when when
he wins
but uh hikaru of course has very much
made a name for himself
in these online rapid tournaments uh
this is sort of his bread and butter
this is what he does and levon aronian
you know sort of seen as as one of the
uh the more classical over-the-board
kind of guys
not especially known for his online
performances but
here we see that he is just as capable
as anybody else in the field
of going all the way in fact losing only
in the finals
to timor rajab and if you're curious
about those games stay tuned for the end
game class because they played some
really nice end games
but for now we are looking at levon
ironian against the karnakamura
and our story starts in a london defense
with bishop f4 or london system i don't
know why i always say defense but london
system
we see e6 by hikaru e3 by levon
and an early bishop d6 by garu nakamura
so this is one of the many ways that
black can play against the london system
but i wanted to really highlight lavon's
opening choices here in the game
there are a lot of moves that white can
choose from for example bishop g3
is by far the most common bishop d6 is
also widely accepted as a move but levon
simply ignores the threat of bishop
takes f4 and this is an idea
that is becoming more and more common
these days
and the idea is that after bishop b5
check as played in the game
by the way this one is a bit of a
novelty by lavonne
we do see it in ipd7 and simply c3
so what's what's the big deal why are we
allowing black
to fracture white's pawn structure with
bishop takes f4
well increasingly often uh we're seeing
that players are allowing this trade
and even even players with the black
pieces are simply declining to do it
and that is because this pawn structure
uh
this one right here actually shows up
quite a bit
and it's a lot better than you might
expect you might think that this is just
a weakening
idea where we now are stuck with two
f-pawns but it actually does give white
a great
deal of freedom both in the center and
to play moves like
f5 so this is a structure that i really
recommend
you guys don't shy away from with either
either color sometimes you do see it
with black as well
because i do think it leads to quite fun
positions and i think they are quite
objectively good
for the side with the double pawns it
greatly
increases your control over the e5
square making moves like 95
much more achievable and it comes at at
seemingly little cost
right now you can still play g3 to guard
the king's side dark squares
and if an annoying knight lands on e4
you even have the opportunity to play
f3 yourself to kick it away even though
you already have
the powerful pawn on f4 so fun stuff i
just
wanted to really highlight this opening
choice by levon allowing bishop takes f4
and notably hikaru simply declines to go
in
for this structure we see knight bd2 and
queen e7 by karu
so again both sides fully accepting that
bishop takes f4 and e takes f4
is something that is pretty reasonable
for
white now though that opportunity goes
away
as we see levon playing the classic
london idea of occupying the e5 square
black responds with knight to e4 we see
a capture on e4
and d takes e4 and this is a decision
that i wanted to talk about because it
really shows up
in many many many positions again with
both colors
in d4 d5 openings at least
so what what is this decision to play
knight e4
uh allowing these pawns to become
doubled and why
is it made what is the upside to this
decision what is the downside
so i wanted to ask the chat that first
before i give my take on it
so chat room what do you think of this
decision by
black is it a good one here and why
what what are the general ideas to keep
in mind
what do you think
and yeah this is something out of the
london system
so yeah
at its heart this is an idea to gain
central space right uh someone in the
chat mentioned that f6 f5 is coming
and yes it is in this case
so what happens when we play a move like
d takes e4
or conversely for white a move like d
takes e5
well more often than not the story
revolves around
whether or not you can take advantage of
the extra squares
that this pawn controls and in this case
i think it is actually a bad decision by
hikaru
to go for this structure uh and that's
you know that's my my take on it i've
done a little bit of work but i'm sure
karo knows a lot more than me
should always preface uh but i do think
it's a bad decision by ikaro
in this case because you simply cannot
make use of the extra space
right uh you're not going to be able to
launch any kind of king's side attack
your pieces are just not well set up for
it so
controlling the f3 square keeping the
knight out of f3
doesn't really help you and controlling
the d3 square which is often the idea
when you see it from the white point of
view the idea is to
try and get a knight into d3 or
conversely d6
if the roles were reversed that's also
simply not going to happen
so i'm sort of wondering what made
hikaru
really want to uh to go for this idea i
assume it was the king side attack
but as we'll see in the game it simply
was not going to uh
not going to be successful in this case
so
that leaves us with the question how do
we punish black for
taking this extra space but allowing a
weakness in the structure
and the idea is very simple this pawn is
a weakness
it's super far advanced it's doubled so
white should attack it with a move like
queen c2
and that's exactly what happens uh in
the game here
now it's not too late for black to play
a move like knight f6 and try to keep
things a little bit calm
but this is going to run into ideas like
bishop g5 later on
and honestly even even slower ideas just
repositioning the pieces
this pawn is going to remain going to
remain a weakness
so instead hikaru commits to the idea
with
f5 and on the surface this does look
rather frightening right g5 might be
coming
some sort of pawn storm against the
king's side but lavon's next
couple moves do a really great job of
trying to defuse this attack
we see bishop takes d7 bishop takes d7
and now h4 so first lavon cements his
control over the dark squares
and then plays h4 to make sure that
these uh
g5 ideas are really not going to come
into play
and with the this sequence of moves i
really don't see the future of the
attack for hikaru
and i don't see the reason for the new
weakness
that has been created along this light
squared diagonal right
just because you've played f5 to defend
the e4 pawn doesn't mean you've solved
all your problems you've just sort of
created
different problems with the pawn on e6
bishop e5 is the continuation now
for hikaru and we do see
that he's aiming to get some some sort
of attack going
on the light squares lavon follows up
with
a4 and now we actually see
a huge change in the position bishop
takes e5 bishop takes e5
bishop d3 and queen b3
and after this i think caro has done a
good job of
making sure that the position didn't get
out of hand if
that's knight was sort of left on e5 i
i think things could have gone pretty
badly for for black
uh in in the reasonably near future
but with this night gone uh we have
entered a different kind of position and
that kind of position
is one with opposite colored bishops
so i want to get the chat's take on what
the plans
should be now that we are in this pure
opposite color bishop position
with three major pieces on the board for
either side
what should we be aiming to do here
uh jacob is asking is this already close
to winning for white
and yet definitely not not uh especially
now
i would say that it you know white may
not even have a positional edge
anymore now that's this powerful knight
on e5
has gone away and we see both sides sort
of with the powerful bishop i would say
that's positionally black is the side
with with more weaknesses right now
but uh that's definitely not enough to
be
close to winning
uh jacob was talking a few moves earlier
and yeah i think white was a lot better
a few moves earlier but close to winning
would definitely be
a big stretch
okay so a lot of people are focusing on
the kings and that is exactly what you
should do
in positions of obstacle bishops with
major pieces
on the board so these opposite color
bishop positions sort of have a bad
reputation for
being you know drawn and boring like
you've heard that before you know
position
end games with bishops opposite colors
are boring but
when there are major pieces on the board
then it's an entirely different story
then
the positions actually can become quite
dangerous
for either side's king and the reason
for that
is exactly what you see here with
black's bishop and with white's bishop
these bishops are essentially
unassailable
because they can never be threatened to
trade off
and they attack squares that are very
very difficult to defend
for the opposing side again because
these bishops are playing on
you know sort of in in different realms
right black is always going to struggle
to defend the dark squares because his
bishop can never defend it
and white is always going to struggle to
defend the light squares
because this bishop on e5 can also never
defend them
so what does this mean well this means
with major pieces you can really start
to
start to create threats that are
difficult to parry
uh because the attacking side is
essentially playing a piece up
with their with their bishop so in these
positions
even if it does appear to be reasonably
equal at the moment
uh the tide can change very very quickly
and you do have to be very very cautious
to ensure that yours is the side with
the better uh king so both sides should
really just be aiming right now
to make sure that their king is safe and
to do everything in their power to make
sure that the opponent's king
is not and we'll see what they do about
that first and foremost levon aronian is
threatening to capture a pawn on b7
so hikaru nakamura says i will defend my
pawn thank you very much
and now we see a really interesting move
by
lavon aronian uh and that move is
f4 so with f4 lavon is doing quite a bit
uh number one he's making sure
that f4 is not going to be played by
black opening up things around
white's king number two he's giving this
king
a flight square and sort of ensuring
that it has
a place to stay notably by the way we
do not see levon ever touching this g
pawn
because every pawn on a light square it
can actually be
quite a valuable defender for uh
for for your king right so with this
pawn on g2
it controls two light squares that white
would otherwise have a very difficult
time
of controlling that that's what i'm sort
of getting at here um
but i do think it may not be the best
move
because of hikaru's response here and
i'm not even talking about
pawn takes pawn on passat i don't think
this is actually a very good idea
for black to try to do here because
after pawn takes this bishop is actually
going to get evicted
and then again it's all about king's
safety and white's king
is by far the safer king in this
position even sorry queenside castles is
probably
a lot better than king d2 that i was
highlighting richie one comes
and the king is very unsafe but i want
to ask you guys
what do you think hikaru's move should
be in this position
and why it's it's a pretty deep idea
it's a pretty impressive find
by caro in my opinion pretty impressive
find
[Music]
jacob says c5 which is a reasonable move
and yeah the move is actually h5 and you
might be thinking that this is an idea
to control g4 and to
like lock things down uh and while you
you might be
correct in that regard i think the idea
is actually a little bit deeper
and it goes back to lavon's move of f4 i
actually don't believe
f4 was the best move in the position
because i think lavonne
should have actually been the one to
play the move h5
now why do i believe that h5 is the
better move
well it comes down to what i talked
about with this g pawn
right as it sits on g2 for white it's a
powerful defender of the light squares
one of the few defenders
of the light squares and black is facing
a similar
sort of situation with the pawn on g7 so
with h5
let's say black plays some improving
move like c5 for example
now after h6 black is going to be forced
to weaken these dark squares even
further and that is going to go a long
way
towards ensuring that the black king is
going to struggle to find safety so h5
h6 is a very powerful idea
by white now hikara of course could
still stop this pawn in its tracks with
h6
but now perhaps h6
is creating more targets in the position
it's not like a travesty for black or
anything
but i think this would have been a
really interesting idea to to see played
out right we can see
for example these light squares also
falling under fire and the pawn on h6
itself might become a target
to sacrifices or just to to attack
so h5 would have been interesting to see
instead though we see f4
and hikaru finds the opportunity to play
h5 himself and ensure that these moves
do not happen okay now let's see how the
game continues
king king f2 king h7 and
rook h3 and this is sort of the downside
to hikaru's having played the move of h5
now of course whenever uh this pawn was
on h7
it could potentially step the g pawn
could potentially step to g6 if it
needed to
and have some support by black's pawn
now
this is no longer really an option here
and hikaru's next move i am willing to
call
just sort of a flat out mistake so like
i said
uh defenders of dark squares for black
are sort of few and far between
and really hard to come by and hikaru
chooses to play the move g6
which i think is sort of just just a a
very very bad move right you weaken all
these dark squares and after this move i
think it's very very clear
that white is the side with an advantage
and that is is pretty easily realized by
levon aronian
so what should black have done instead
well the the problem is
this is already a rather tough position
for
for black you can try the move c5 but i
think rook g3
is still going to be coming and after g6
you have a lot of the same problems as
before
with this pawn on g6 being quite weak i
should mention by the way this is never
really an issue
because moves like queen takes e6 are
difficult to stop
and i think even ideas like rook h1
should be
should be working here with rook takes
g7 being good enough
with the queen invading as well so
perhaps then this move king h7 and this
idea of h5
were a little bit flawed after all as uh
levon ironian
does find some way to make
make use of the weaknesses around the
black can
uh so h5 king f2 and rook h3
really cool stuff to see from uh levon
aronian here
seemingly making it making an advantage
out of nothing so we do see rook g3
now c5 is the move by naka
rook g5 is pretty intuitive by lavon
stopping up this queen
and cementing this rook on a powerful
dark square
king h6 is a cars move and now we see d
takes c5
b takes c5 and c4 so
a pretty interesting decision here by
levon
uh i don't know if it was strictly
necessary to to take on c5 and open up
the b
file but notably it's very difficult to
make use of this b
file with the dark square dominance that
white already has
and with c4 white is actually looking to
invade further
on these dark squares cargo anticipates
this and plays the move rook f7 to guard
the g7 square
we see between queen c3 anyways and the
car
now does try to make use of this newly
opened b file
we see a5 by lavon
a space gaining move trying to threaten
some a6 ideas when maybe the pawn on c5
can be targeted
rook c8 is caro's idea and now b3
comes on the board by lavon another move
which i'm not sure was strictly
necessary but
you know it's it's fine keeping the
balance queen c6 now is the move
from hikaru perhaps trying to bring a
rook to the b file rather than the queen
and now uh i want to ask you guys
how should white continue i sort of sped
through some moves there
both players were doing some maneuvering
lavon pushing a couple puns
but nothing really drastic was changing
in the position
but here i think lavon makes a key
decision and i'm interested to see
what you guys in the chat think should
should be played
[Music]
and the chat is talking about perhaps
sacrificing the exchange for black
and i have some doubts about that but we
can take a look
so the chat is going down the road that
lavon actually went down
which is the road of pile up on this
king side
and try and find some sort of winning
idea
but here i believe lavon actually only
really had
one way to push the the advantage
uh that was totally working and that was
in fact with this idea of a6
i'm not really sure why levon plays the
move a5 but then
never really goes on to play the the the
follow through of the idea
which is to put the pawn on a6 but i
think this is the best way to continue
now why is this so strong well after a
move like queen b6 for example
i'm gonna see the move rick a5 and now
uh black is is fighting a battle on on
two fronts right that that should always
be your goal
is to create two weaknesses and force
your opponent to stretch their
their forces a little bit thin uh
between controlling those two weaknesses
so by
creating a second weakness on the queen
side i think white would have had a much
easier time
trying to break through uh through all
of the craziness
uh and through black's defense in order
to win the game
instead we see white going rook h1 which
i don't think is a bad idea
but perhaps shouldn't have objectively
worked
hikaru now does continue with his idea
of rook b7
uh but now we do see rook h3
rook g8 and rick hg3
and king h7 and now levon says
i am going to put every last one of my
pieces uh
on on this attack on the king's side and
wish you the best
hikaru sort of matches this this task
with the idea of queen g6
and i do want to mention the idea after
the move rook takes b3 is pretty
interesting here
uh you can simply go queen d1 and now no
matter what is played
by uh well sorry your rook is attacked
no matter what is played by black you
can actually sacrifice the queen or the
rook
and take on h7 or of course if you try
to defend
then then the rook simply falls also
importantly
b2 is covered so rook b3 not playable
instead hikaru plays queen eight
but now queen d1 is still creating more
threats
and unfortunately for recaro he did
crack under the pressure
uh what black had to play was the move
queen f7
just sort of sitting back and saying all
right i have everything covered uh and
i'm surviving the game for the moment
it's it's your job to find some way to
break through
and unfortunately for white there there
simply isn't a way to break through
and that's why i think this idea of rook
a6 and rk5 may have been better
because as it is black only has one
thing to worry about
and hikaru would have been able to
accurately deal with it with queen f7
instead we see the move rook d7 by
black and this surprisingly
gives white an opportunity to win the
game
so chat room white to move and win
against the move rook d7 what should be
played jacob says there isn't some
future zug in that position
well here's the deal right you have one
two three pieces attacking black has one
two three pieces defending and sort of
two pieces left over
right so black is always going to be
able to shuffle with this rook shuffle
with
oh maybe not shuffle with the bishop but
uh do do enough with these pieces that
that it's not going to be
a zuck and yeah the the idea is rook
takes g6
and this is the idea that allows lavon
to go on
to win the game point now is that if you
were to take with the rook
we can play queen takes h5 rook h6 is
unplayable
because of queen takes on e8 this is why
queen f7 had to be played
because here against rook takes g6
there is the simple idea of rook h6 when
the queen is on a square
where it is defended so
instead though rook d7 rook g6 is good
enough hikaru has to sack the queen for
the two rooks
but after king takes g6 the queen is
going to be far
more powerful in this position than the
two rooks
and the reason for that is this weakness
around
the black king it's true that in general
the two rooks
tend to be superior to the queen but in
positions where the kings are very very
weak
oftentimes that is the time for the
queen to shine
yes okay king g1 played in the game and
now we're going to see
lavon ensuring that his own king is safe
before weaving around with the
with his own queen into enemy territory
queen e7 and it's it's already over for
hikaru once this queen
is able to access these dark squares the
rooks have not been able to coordinate
and checkmate is is sort of imminent uh
hikaru actually resigns here the game
could have continued with queen f6
queen f7 and something like bishop f6
bishop g5
with uh checkmate uh being unavoidable
so really cool games from the this
airling
airling air air things masters very
difficult for me to say
the names of these like norwegian
sponsored tournaments for some reason i
don't know why
but yeah really fun games that do above
mvl game is one of the craziest games
i've seen come out of these online
tournaments
and then really fun to see lavon ironian
in good form
uh congratulations though to team
rajabov whose games
we are actually going to be analyzing in
the following class
the end game class uh as he did go on
to win the entire tournament uh this has
been the road to 2000. as always my name
is caleb denby
thank you so much for watching and i
will see you next time
you